one of the things we've talked about on
the show for a long time is that there
seems to be something sort of
constitutional that's lowercase C I mean
with the constitution of the of the
right the the way the right is
where uh sort of like satire parody and
to some degree comedy
um are just sort of like not working on
the right and so an example of that
would be this there was this old show
that was supposed to challenge Jon
Stewart's The Daily Show years ago it
was called the half hour news hour and
it it just wasn't funny and it failed
very very quickly
and we've seen a lot of these right-wing
comedians
um just fail to be Comedians and the new
like least funny man in America now is
this guy named Jim Brewer now we've
talked about Jim Brewer before he's
become kind of like an anti-vaxx laugh
at fauci uh laugh at science type of
right right wing comedian and it's like
what does that even mean at this point
in time and he really seems to have kind
of lost his grip with reality there's a
new video that was published by the
reawaken America American Faith tour
this is he's been going around with this
like religious revival kind of tour and
we played a clip of that in the past and
he did a video for them where he's now
talking I guess this is I don't even
know what he's talking about I guess
this is supposed to be a commentary on
Joe Rogan
and foreign policy
although it's hard to tell what this is
but the right thinks that this is funny
whereas I see a guy who's lost his
connection to reality probably worthy of
a psych eval take a look at this that I
think they think this is funny maybe the
voices are supposed to be funny what
happened was people like hey what are
you
[Music]
and also I was like Crusher wants to go
to war and uh people like do they really
want to go to war yeah ah Russia you
know what um no more mandates uh maybe
some mandates uh
like what is the critique here is the
critique that there are things in the
news like I I am not I don't know what
is what is the point here Logan's a
problem
they are losing grip the Wright loves
this guy I'm going to show you a video
in a second where they're in hysterics
it's almost like is do you normally
watch paint dry to the point where this
is entertaining but beware
because when you're in power that long
you're not going down without a vicious
foam at the mouth battle and I don't
know what that's gonna do I mean I see
it now if they're trying to do to Joe
this is a psychological War it is an
American War when the White House says
we need to censor
a human being that allows conversation
guess what everyone you just been taken
over and you're just sitting there
taking it and you can buy all you want
that oh well and then when it doesn't
sell they send their Stars what on Earth
is this guy talking about I mean really
like if the point of that is to defend
Rogan
I don't know that that's very helpful to
Rogan to be perfectly honest it just
seems like the rantings of an unhinged
person just as a reminder this was
Brewer's in-person performance at this
American Faith reawaken America Tour
talking about fauci and and some other
things and if you're watching you'll see
that the the crowd is in hysterics are
these must be the most sheltered people
in the world to find this funny you know
what a cockatoo is
cockatoo
yeah
look at the crowd
[Laughter]
and that that's what everyone's become
right
little cockatoo staring at the screen
he goes back
whoa I guess you're right masks must not
work based on this routine right now
disclaimer I'm not saying masks don't
work just to be clear I don't want to
end up getting in trouble myself
trust the science trust the science
now as I've said before
he did trust the science when sadly his
wife needed cancer treatment and he said
with no hint of irony
we are trusting the science we're
finding the best Specialists we're
finding the people who know about this
stuff that's who we're following we're
not following Hannity recommending zinc
or you know whatever so he's also a
complete and total hypocrite but the
right finds this funny and that should
scare us as much as anything else we see
going on right now uh within that
right-wing cultural movement one of our
sponsors is nebia who's introducing
their newest shower head the nebia by
mon cuatro it was designed by former
NASA Engineers who spent years
researching how to save water cuatro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and Quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install all easy as screwing
in a light bulb I love it I have the
rain shower version I've been using
nebia shower heads for a while now I
love saving the water and I love the
high pressure spray it's really The Best
of Both Worlds nebia the maker of
Quattro also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories I have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
Quattro shower head is just 119 dollars
but nebia is giving you 10 off when you
go to nebia.com Pacman and use the promo
code Pacman the link is underneath this
video